[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode Lo
let me be clear before this podcast
begins we are loud proud and do not give
a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them so when your attorney uh pleads
guilty is that bad I I mean just going
to go out on a limb here just say that
if your
attorney in the criminal case that
you're in one of them that was defending
you be like oh yeah the election was
stolen hugate Chavez and election
machines and two space lasers and space
force and Watermark ballot and release
the
Kraken oh the kraken's released you dumb
asses manga's gonna be super sad today I
mean super
sad as you may have known or know now
Sydney pal is a criminal and has pled
guilty to six criminal misdemeanors this
morning in election interference that's
right she has admitted in court to not
one not two not three not four not five
but six criminal charges related to the
election interference that she
participated in criminally as a RICO
conspiracy in Georgia two days ahead of
her trial as you know Sydney the cracken
pal decided she wanted a speedy trial
well how the [__] did that work out
where you dumb
[__] [__] around find out moment is
coming for MAA now I want to remind
everyone today is a good day to remind
everyone everyone out there that Sydney
pal not only is she the Kraken Not only
was she at the press conference where
Rudy giuliani's hair was leaking the
[__] was leaking out of his scalp
she was in the White House planning this
election
interference with Donald Trump
folks and I don't know if you remember
exactly who was with her in the White
House planning this election
interference with Donald Trump but his
name was General Michael Flynn now
Michael Flynn was was deposed in this
Georgia case he gave testimony in this
Georgia case Maya assumption here is
that Mike Flynn turned on these [__]
idiots that's my
assumption because Sydney poell was Mike
Flynn's attorney in his criminal case
where he lied to the FBI where Donald
Trump pardoned him H I just I I wonder I
wonder if any of this [__] had anything
to do with each other when they were
meeting in the white house if they ever
brought this [__] up you think they you
think they just didn't bring that kind
of [__] up do you think you think it was
like Hey if you do this then you can do
this and if you'll do that then I'll
scratch your back this way H I wonder if
any of that stuff came up wonder and I
wonder if Sydney pal is now PL pleading
guilty to six misdemeanor charges
getting six years probation that's a
hell of a [__] deal folks oh my
[__] God you have no clue how sweet
of a deal Sydney pal got this morning
these right Wingers is like oh Hunter P
got such a sweet deal and had a
Delaware they have no clue the deal that
Sydney pal made made this morning is
huge she only had to she only had to
plead to six
misdemeanor and she got six years
probation are you listening she's not
going to go to jail not only that she is
required to
testify now cheeseboro trial is going to
start here real soon that's why Sydney
pal [__] tuck tailed and run and the
reason why I think that is is because of
um what's that word that is so important
in law
Discovery they I think I believe this is
just my [__] feeling
here just my feeling I I don't have any
evidence to bear this out other than
what we know already in the
public but my feeling is that Sydney
Pal's attorneys and Sydney pal looked at
this evidence and realized that Mike
Flynn had turned on
her that there was [__] that only her
and Mike Flynn and a few others would
know and that's where the RICO charges
are coming from at a Coffee County when
and and to lay it on even more the bail
bondsman I think that's what he was
remember this guy the first guy to plead
guilty I don't know it was last week or
two weeks ago or three I don't know you
can't you can't keep up with Republican
criminals godamn you can't even they
can't even figure out who speaker is how
we supposed to figure out which criminal
charges and which ones are which ones
are charged with what crimes at this
point it's all [__] confusing isn't
it that's more news about the Republican
house caucus if you want to call it a
house caucus [__] what a joke what a
joke the Republican party is Holy actual
[__] are you kidding me
this is the best they got this Dr Pepper
drinking perjury fool the
kranken she's turning on them she's the
one who sat and now now it seems I mean
in
hindsight that she was [__] lying to
the January 6 select committee under
oath because now she's admitting in
court that she did commit election
interference she was in on the
conspiracy to overturn the election in
Donald Trump's favor when Joe Biden won
[__] dude Donald Trump didn't win
you're just in a [__] cult man I hate
to break it to you and I know I know it
doesn't feel like it
yet well this is all deep State's
fault this is just the Deep State
getting to the
Kraken there no there's no person really
in this whole [__] in this whole
goddamn
theatrics of the election interference
that is more qinon than this brain dead
idiot she was talking about voting
machines and Hugo Chavez and all kinds
of crazy [__] in the moment so much so
that they wouldn't let her in front of a
microphone you remember that do you
remember Grandpa farty Mardy Rudy
Giuliani Jenna Ellis Jenna I caught coid
from giuliani's farts Ellis and Sydney
pal the Kraken gave a press conference
after that press conference she said
such crazy [__] more crazier [__] than
what Rudy Giuliani and Jenna Ellis could
handle that they took her away from the
microphone like more Looney Tune [__]
than [__] Lynn wood you remember Lynn
wood he was an attorney in Georgia he
[__] flipped on these sons of [__]
in Georgia he [__] relinquished his
law license so he wouldn't go to jail or
lose his law license he
retired do you see the [__] pattern
here you [__]
eaters yeah I'm talking to you manga do
you see the [__] pattern here you
dumb sons of
[__] are you gonna get it eventually
like are you gonna get it through your
thick [__] head ever are we just
gonna have to keep yelling and screaming
this [__] until the end of time CU you
people are so [__] brain dead and you
can't find in a brain El to rub together
to put together a thought in your mind
that oh maybe it's not the Deep State
maybe maybe Republicans just suck and it
sucks to
suck when are you gonna get it through
your thick [__] heads huh how many
times are we going to have to do this
it's going to be a lot I can tell you
we're going to do it in Michigan with
those fake State
electors we're probably going to do it
before the before this cheeseboro trial
kicks off
we're definitely going to do it in South
Florida on this documents case oh you
guys are so [__] there oh my God you
guys are so [__] it doesn't matter how
far Canon kicks his can down the
road that shit's gonna [__] around and
come around and find out on your dumb
asses this this only this only
strengthens the case in Washington DC
that is put against your mango musolini
Jesus where he tried to attempt a coup
on our
government when the [__] are you
boneheads going to wake the [__] up huh
we're not asking you to agree with this
I know you're still going to be a
scumbag like you're going to be fighting
to take away women's health care you're
going to be trying to tear down our
public education system to make sure
people are dumber than rocks so that way
you can convince them of this stupid
[__] I understand that I get that you're
going to try to press your religion on
us you're going to try to make sure that
we are the way you want us to be and
you're going to be all fashy and [__] I
get it I get it I'm not trying to
convince you not to be a [__] Nazi
okay I'm not real I mean I know you're
gonna be you [__]
idiots and I'm talking to Manga
Here I get it I I know you're this is
just a personality treat that you
[__] [__] have but when the [__]
are you finally going to admit I mean
you you're outright admitting that you
guys are [__] fascists and Nazis I
mean Jesus Christ your surrogates are
standing on overpasses howling Hitler
and DeSantis down in Florida they're
going to Texas goddamn Nick Fuentes went
to Texas did one interview and like 30
people are [__] fired
now because they were poing around with
a goddamn
Nazi so we know we know who and what you
are and you know who and what you are we
get it it's not a [__] secret but
when are you going to just wake up and
realized that maybe you should move on
to the next [__] Hitler that you want
right that Grandpa poopy pants just
ain't gonna [__] survive
here I mean I get it you're gon to make
him your nominee you [__] love him
you're going to try to protect the lies
that you've been telling for [__]
years here because that's the truth
that's audience that's what they that's
what they really are trying to [__]
do
they're really trying to not convince us
that they're correct they're trying to
convince themselves at this point it's
pathetic I mean just look at the House
of
Representatives Jim Jordan lost by more
votes yesterday than he did the day
before there was more [__] you in the
Republican Party against Jim Jordan and
Donald
Trump what was there 22 yesterday is
that what it was 22 [__] you votes out
of the Republican caucus apparently
their WI and their loved ones and
they're getting death threats in their
email and on their personal cell phones
and
[__] who do you who do you think is who
do you think is orchestrating the
[__] death threats and the threats to
these people the 22 huh who do you think
is doing that I wonder who could it be I
wonder oh boy it's hard to figure out
isn't
it I mean honestly you know a lot of the
and a lot of the left out there really
you know they want like order in the
house and they want someone to be the
speaker and all that kind of [__] I
actually want you [__] idiots to fail
I want the entire [__] world to see
how much of a [__] feckless party you
truly are because you are you are
[__] worthless Republicans and maanga
you are [__] worthless you are not
you're not even worth the time of day
anymore I can't even believe we have to
sit here and talk about about your dumb
asses you're so
irrelevant you can't even pick a
speaker not only can you not pick a
speaker 22 people are telling Donald
Trump to [__] off in the Republican
Party think about that for a second
think about it just just think about
what you're putting this entire country
through because you're in a cult and the
cult is more important than our
democracy think about it think about it
for a second let it sink in you [__]
[__]
eaters I'm talking to Manga Here listen
turn the [__] [__] up if you need to
I don't know if you need to I'm yelling
screaming to the microphone but goddamn
turn it up if you need
to 22 votes and those votes were not
against Jim Jordan you stupid bastards
those votes were to send a message to
Donald
Trump you know that right even Byron
Donalds I showed you the clip yesterday
even Byron Donald's got out there and oh
I wish the internet people would leave
us alone and let us do our
business oh
godamn so I guess I guess they're not
gonna have a third Jim Jordan vote today
and the reason why is because we know
the results already it's not [__]
rocket
surgery these people can't govern they
can't even if they wanted to they
couldn't they don't want to is really
the actual point
because Donald Trump wants the
government shut down so this morning I
guess the the Hail Mary pass here to
keep the government
open is to appoint the Elf on the Shelf
Patrick McKenry
McKenry as the interterm speaker until
January folks listen to me what I what
I'm telling you the last speaker he did
a deal with the Democrat rats to keep
the government open for 45 days and they
were running laps like they [__] won
the Super
Bowl he gets vacated with one goddamn
vote from Matt gats on the or one one
motion on the floor from Matt
gats and he gets vacated with eight
votes eight from the Republican caucus
eight votes were [__]
Ed to Kevin
McCarthy and they're savior Donald
Trump's savior in the house to be
speakers Jim Jordan and he gets 22 fucku
against him from Republicans this is not
going well their 45 day CR stop Gap as
it were is not the [__] is not the
great Victory it once seemed is
it and they want they want to punt this
thing to get an interterm speaker until
January
I don't know if you see what's going on
but they know they know they have to
keep the government open now they're
really
[__] they're really [__] with the
with the conflict going on over in the
Middle
East with Israel and Gaza City after
Hamas committed terrorist attacks and
committed war crimes and murdered and
slaughtered civilians with that conflict
going
on they have to keep the government open
they can't appear they're shutting it
down they're they've already lost the
house
folks they're not going to win the house
in in November all we got to do is do
our job and keep yelling and screaming
and pointing out how [__] ridiculous
these idiots
are it's all we have to keep doing
really I mean they'll they'll keep trust
me they're not going to let us down oh
my God they're they are not going to let
us down to be a clown show an absolute
circus there's no way they're going to
let us down down not a chance in
hell we can count on them being
[__] for
sure there there's nothing I mean really
honestly if there's one thing that's the
most sure thing that we've ever known
about
Republicans in the last 40 years right
now in this moment they absolutely will
capitulate to Donald
Trump
100% maybe not all of them but enough of
them to not be able to govern to not
keep the government open to look
feckless to look like they're not doing
the America people American people's
work and right before the holidays too
you know that you know that messaging is
coming
right they're going to shut this [__]
down and like what what what what do we
got less than what we got 30 less than
30 days or something
is it the 17th of
November right before the holidays I
mean right
before do you notice how Democrats
played this to the tea you know the
Republicans really want to blame
Democrats here because that's what they
always do it's always someone else's
fault oh God damn it's not our fault it
can't be our fault we love Jesus and
[__] it's always a democrat's fault
right
Kevin McCarthy needed to keep the
government open the best he could do is
get a stop Gap and the Democrats are
like yeah sure we'll do 45 days that's
right before the holidays you dumb [__]
try to shut the government down right
before the holidays that'll go well for
you you see how that worked out
right here they
are always jumping on
rakes and they can't stop honestly I
don't I don't
know there's probably going to be a rake
shortage in this country The Rake
factories are really going to have to
[__] work overtime I mean it's going
to create thousands of American jobs
creating or building this many rakes for
Republicans to jump on to be perfectly
honest I mean at this point they're
[__] job graders aren't
they they're [__] job graders look at
them look at them Harold look at them
creating all those rake jobs they can't
build enough [__]
rates speaking of
factories I bet the ketchup factories
are really working overtime aren't they
oh my God I'm sure I'm sure they're
getting prepared for the ketchup
shortage that is about to
come from Donald Trump after he after he
hears the Sydney pal is turned on
him again
I you know I I Can't Describe to you you
manga idiots out there that are
listening because I know we we got the
hate Watchers here and a lot of times
are just lurking you know some of them
some of them uh come in the chat but a
lot of them are just lurking here but we
have we have the people who love me and
the people who love to hate me and
really honestly I I I like I love that
the people who love to hate me are here
lurking
listening getting this kind of
propaganda this Pro democracy propaganda
pumped into their [__]
skulls maybe with a little bit of brain
energy they have left they can form a
thought or two with
it but here's the
thing
folks we just have to mock the [__] out
of them we have to let them throw the
rakes in front of
themselves [__] them [__] them what the
[__] are you going to try to save them
for we've we've done this for the last
four [__] decades to save the
Republican party from themselves and
what has it got us what what do we have
to show for saving the Republican party
from themselves for the last four
[__] decades and I get
it I get it that you know oh it's bad
for the institution and it's bad for our
country yes it is it's horrible for our
country that we have such a feckless
Republican party that they're such
fascist that they can't think about
anything but them [__] themselves and
their own [__] power yeah right I get
it but maybe we would be better off if
we just let them [__] burn themselves
you know what I mean just let it burn
[__] it don't put out the fire anymore
let the [__] dumpster fire that the
Republican party of manga is burn to the
[__] ground [__]
him that's why that's
why the [__] phrase works so goddamn
well that's why so many people cheer and
scream when I say
it because they want to say it because
they feel the same way they're [__]
sick of the left saving the rights ass
every time every [__]
time it gets it gets [__] it gets it
gets exhausting really honestly that
Kevin McCarthy wants Democrats to save
them now Jim Jordan and the rest of the
Republicans want Democrats to save them
get the [__] out of here with this
nonsense we didn't get elected to put
you [__] idiots in power okay we did
not go vote for democrats for people who
believe in democracy to put you [__]
people who want to use democracy to kill
it in power get the [__] out of here
with this [__] [__]
you this is your [__] bed you [__]
made it now sleep in
it you
cowards you're just [__] cowards you
can't own up to the fact that your mango
musolini Jesus is a complete utter
[__]
loser and it doesn't matter what you do
or how you try to do it everything that
you do your entire existence your entire
personality is to protect him and his
fraudulent
image you [__] Bon
heads keep
going [__] around find out there's a
million ways to say it there really
is and honestly the pro-democracy
Coalition in this country should just
look at each other and stand back and go
you know
what eventually they're gonna have to
touch the hot stove because they're just
not going to [__] listen to us
they're not going to listen to us that
when you try to use democracy to kill it
it's not going to go well for
you especially in a country where
there's woke wokers oh you're woke man
you know stuff about government and
stuff oh man you're like you're like
into that equity and equality stuff
aren't you like the Constitution and
democracy oh you're so
woke Jesus [__] Christ
man well we're going to keep going
though we're going to keep [__] with
you and we're going to keep mocking you
appropri
at least here on the Tony Michaels
podcast that's for damn sure there's
some on the left that don't know how to
do this media thing and mock your asses
there's some that don't don't know how
to get inside your [__] brains and
live rentree [__] yesterday I showed you
this hat hang on I showed you this hat
and you all [__] responded I got a
lot of thank yous to give out for for
making sure that we get a couple more
hats I'm going to show you those uh
today if I can but I I want to thank
Uncle fatty Tammy
theren as well I got a few more thank
you here some people sent some hats
money I I found two of them that's very
similar oh it's really gonna piss them
off oh [__] they these hats are gon
they're gonna have comments down in the
shorts oh did your mommy buy you that
hat did your mommy buy you that hat
let's see here we have Nicholas uh we
have Derek Cynthia and Kim I sent some
hat money in so thank you very much for
to all of you who not only support the
show but uh supported the effort to get
some more hat
rage it's so funny when you when you
make a good point in a video and it's
clipped and the best they could come up
with is oh your hat sucks okay all right
man keep coming back keep commenting on
my hat I'm I'm cool with that so I
appreciate all the support and if you
want to support the show don't forget to
go to the Tony michaels.com that's right
you can go to the Tony
michaels.com it's right here let me show
it to you well maybe if I can get my my
pter to work there we go there we go hit
subscribe at the top of the page here
you can always see the very current
episode that's the one we're right now
504 504 episodes of the Tony Michaels
podcast can you believe that [__] holy
[__] I couldn't do it without you
folks you're the ones who keep this
microphone on I could not do it without
you so if you want to show live show
support you can buy me a shot of Jagger
I did a few shots last night H you can
get in on the vinmo super chat if you
want to send me a message I'll bring it
up on the screen here just click this
link here VMO Super Chat make sure if
you want credit that you put what
platform you're on in your screen name
so I can give you a shout out there and
if you just want to you know support the
show and the swearing and the swear jar
if you swear like me stick some money in
the swear jard there you can also go to
the memberships section where you can
you can follow me on patreon for free
now that's right you can follow for free
you won't see everything if you just
follow but it'll it'll give you insight
to the patreon what's going on over
there and you can consider being a paid
member and I appreciate all the paid
members over there on patreon you also
keep this microphone going and boy are
they chatting over in the Discord server
speaking of free membership it is free
to join the Discord server let me give
you that CH that uh let me give you that
link right now because I think that
important that Discord chat is something
else and not only does it chat during
the live show but it also it
also keeps chatting 247 it's where the
chat party never stops that's right the
Discord server is where the chat party
never stops so the link is in the chat
right now so go join the Discord server
if you get if you get over there to the
Discord server make sure to stop off at
the Welcome Center and verify yourself I
got another uh little thing I want to
want to show you the section on the Tony
Michaels podcast this is important we're
going to be talking more and more and
more about this um I get all kinds of
stories all the time people will send me
DMS on Facebook or Instagram or Twitter
or sometimes you know on on on patreon
in the DMs I get a lot of stories some
people drop links all over the place and
it's hard for me to follow all those
links and all those different places so
what I thought was is look if you want
to submit a story to the Tony Michaels
podcast if if you want me to cover
something you know we we've been keeping
our eye on the Gabriel Hansen Mayoral
race you know that Nazi down in Franklin
Tennessee oh by the way there's an
update on there she did an interview
with a Neo-Nazi oh boy ain't that
something that doesn't make her a Nazi
at all does it uh so she did an
interview with a with a Neo-Nazi but if
you want to stay on if you want us here
at the Tony Michaels podcast to stay on
top of a story because we got so many
talented people in our community I don't
know if you know that over the there on
Discord that's the other thing that
Discord is it's like a community there's
so many talented people in there we
we've got the mighty librarian working
on the library of democracy we got skip
as as the clip maker and producer uh
I've got I've got rat rat is here I
think I think rat's here rat's here
somewhere there there there's rat
there's rat right there there's rat hi
rat rat rat is here working on the
laboratory you know making up a lot of
he's kind of our mad scientist here at
Theon Michael's SP guas behind the
scenes in our mascot we got a rat as a
mascot we don't [__] around on this show
so there's a lot of a lot of great
talented people over at the community on
Discord and so I want to make sure
there's a place for everyone to submit
stories uh if you got a story if you
want to try to get us to follow a story
if you want the community to follow a
story go drop it in the Discord but also
pop it in this little link here if you
go to this if you go to the Tony
michaels.com under submission submit
story to Tony you just fill out this
form it doesn't matter what the story is
just fill out the form and we will try
to catalog it and we will try to get to
it uh so that way we get to the stories
that you guys want the audience wants
and stay on top of because sometimes I
miss updates and stuff and really
honestly you know I run out of time it's
like two hours so I run out of time
especially when we're goofing on these
some [__] we gotta goof on them a
little bit um so but we got a lot of
stuff to come we got a lot of exciting
expansions that we're trying to make and
this is one of them I wanted to make
sure that you guys had a place that you
could submit your news stories to the
Tony Michaels podcast and it's right
here on the Tony michaels.com so just go
to the Tony michaels.com check out all
the links there again go get on the
Discord and join the [__] fam over
there it's a great community that is
building over there now there's more and
more people there and it's not just
about me it's it's about a community
over there a people are like-minded and
like thinking um that want to share
stories and keep up to date and chat
with each other I know you guys you guys
just don't come here for me you come
here for you too like in the chat you
guys support each other that's why
that's why I call you the best audience
in the world because you really
are you're here for each other it's a
fam it is the [__] them fam so don't go
anywhere [__] them fam we'll be right
back right after this we'll be right
back Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michael's
[Music]
podcast
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a magga
Edition I knew I had to give it a try
Babel Maga Edition makes it really easy
to learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacist the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon I was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the words that I'm
struggling with I chose B magga Edition
because it's created by smart white
people like me and now I can't wait to
explore meet new friends and use my new
Maga skills with my in-laws all lives
matter jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show the
Tony Michaels podcast October 19th it's
th Thursday
12:33 eastern
time and the Republican Nazis still
don't have a speaker a poor
[Music]
thing did you see the guy that they
wanted to be speaker they're like yeah
we'll make this guy speaker I'm not
talking about gim I don't report sex
crime Jordan not that guy this guy is um
I think his name is Austin scan or some
[__] I showed you a picture of him
yesterday but I'm going to show you a
video of him here on CNN trying to
explain explain to us how majorities and
minorities in the house
work I wish I wish if the these people
got elected to congress they actually
knew how Congress [__] worked didn't
you don't you like this guy is supposed
to be one of the smart Republicans
folks he's supposed to be one of the
Smart Ones he's not supposed to be one
of the
clowns now we didn't know who this guy
was until like two days ago when they're
trying to find a [__]
speaker and they're looking for the next
Paul
Ryan and Austin from Georgia this is a
representative from Georgia and the
reason why you don't know who the [__]
he is because no one gives a [__] about
this
guy Austin Scott I think his name is
that his name I don't know he looks he
like I I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna show it
to you here I'm I'm gonna tell you that
it really feels like that Austin Scott
here is like an AI re this is he's got
to be
AI right this is not this like this is
not real he's not he's he's and when you
watch this interview of him you're
definitely gonna be like whoa whoa whoa
did they type in the AI machine to [__]
out generic republican from Georgia
named Austin Scott and this is what the
AI [__] out I'm just saying there's a
lot of AI out there nowadays and we're
going to go over this over and over and
over and over again actually matter of
fact I think uh Rat rant do you uh you
got a video right okay rant's got a
video here he wants to show us here
let's let's see um let's see if we can
uh determine if this is if this is just
stupid or if it's
[Music]
AI oh
[Applause]
brother it stupid or is it AI I don't
know we're going to find out here I
think it might be both it might be
really stupid AI here's here's Austin
Scott on CNN trying to explain how
Congress Works he doesn't do a damn good
job because he's a [__] idiot listen
but he let me ask you sir he was
never mcarthy was never in a ho this
de I'm sorry McCarthy was never in a ho
this
de but but speaker McCarthy was elected
and he was the speaker of the house he
was the largest Republican fundraiser
ever uh for us as House Republicans I
mean the Democrats knew what they were
doing when they put up 208 votes to take
him out of out of the speakership and
that's what created uh the current
situation that we're in so then we had a
conference meeting they they didn't take
him out of the speakership I mean you're
you guys
are oh it was the Democrats remember
that Democrat named Matt gats remember
remember rat remember remember that guy
remember him look at the rat there on
screen rat as our mascot how great is
that
thanks for the uh the video
rat so wait a second Matt gats is now a
Democrat is that what I'm supposed to
understand because my memory serves me
the Democrats helped Kevin McCarthy keep
the government open like without
Democrats the government would have shut
down so like military would have lost
their pay the Border would have been
unsecure you know [__] like that [__]
like
that but
representative AI here representative
Nazi AI here oh that's a great nickname
for him isn't it he looks like [__]
AI Am I
Wrong come on did you hear this guy's
response have you seen really bad AI
that doesn't like that doesn't know I
don't know if you guys know this and I
just found this out yesterday skip sent
it to me actually um he sent me some
there is a
twitch AI Jesus I'm not [__] you
this [__] thing is real [__] you know
what if we get that link I'll show you
the son of a [__] it's [__] crazy so
it's Jesus and you just ask it anything
you want like you just ask AI Jesus
whatever you want and AI Jesus will tell
you what the hell it is well maybe this
is maybe Austin Scott isn't actually an
elected Congressman maybe Austin Scott
is literally Republican Nazi AI just
really bad and and and to be honest the
the AI Jesus it's it's pretty [__]
Wild
but it's kind of bad like it's not it's
not bad yeah yeah skip skip says in the
Discord [__] it's an i Nazi you know the
the movie iRobot with Will Smith like
years ago like that shit's coming that
shit's coming folks this guy's I Nazi
he's not real he's
AI oh my
god
oh what in the [__] is going on you know
I I've said for years that we're at the
intersection WrestleMania real life but
maybe maybe just maybe we're at a a
fourth-dimensional intersection of
WrestleMania real life where AI Nazis
exist this is [__] crazy watch this
[__] watch this guy try to try to
compute this stuff in his head and come
up with an AI answer on this but but you
guys you guys are the majority right 96%
of the votes came from Democrats so
Briana I mean I mean just factually
speaking there were only eight republ an
and there were 208 Democrats I mean 208
Democrats but sir who's in the
majority well the Democrats for the
majority of that vote
and oh it's I I don't know if the the
Republicans um need to go back to the
drawing board rat can can you get can
you get them some decent AI so that the
[__] the I naazi can do some can do
some decent [__] math maybe we can
work up a like an AI code for him
because apparent their AI is [__] over
there on the Republican side the Nazis
just don't don't have a proper amount of
of [__] Jesus Christ are you kidding
me also we do have the we do have the
ask Jesus um link and I'm gonna show you
this it's it's wild stuff but uh let me
let me go back to the I naazi here and
see if he can come up with a way to
compute math and that sort of [__] when
we who's in the majority in the House of
Representatives the Republicans are in
the majority but the Democrats provided
the majority of the votes tothy out of
the speakership in fact they provided %
of the votes Republicans provided the
key votes they're in the majority they
can provide enough votes obviously to
put a republican
speaker the Democrats provided 96% of
the votes 208 Democrats voted to remove
the Republican Speaker of the House
eight Republicans voted to remove the
Republican speaker of the house so 96%
of the votes came from Democrats to
remove the Republican speaker of the
house I I will
fundraiser that we've ever had they knew
some interesting it's some interesting
verbal gymnastics I will give you that
um but I want to talk about the future
here I'm just talking about the facts
She's Like H nice Magics there ni nice
Magics there you iazzi okay AI can we
get a can we get a better AI machine to
interview this is [__] ridiculous
this one doesn't even know definitions
or math literally it doesn't know
definitions or math what the [__] [__]
I'm GNA show you I'm going to show you
this U this ass Jesus this AI Jesus it's
way better way better than than the
iazzi way better way better AI
technology 208 Democrats voted yeah
there were the vast majority of the vote
to take Kevin McCarthy out of the
speakership because there's 208
Democrats and and a Democrat is not
going to vote um for a republican that
that's how it [__] works like what
how how how how didn't they program this
into the Republican iazzi into this AI
I'm serious I don't believe this guy is
real he this can't be real right is this
[__] are they just goofing us now
come on
man look at this guy did you see him
there's no way this guy is real we have
to doubt everything these days no matter
where we see it even on TV I'm telling
you when I show you this Republic or
this this uh AI Jesus you're going to
[__] your drawers you're like whoa what
the [__] and I mean yeah it's not that
great now but like two years from now
this AI gesus I'm telling you if they
didn't call it AI Jesus these these
[__] nutbags out there these these
JFK
Jor he didn't die and he's gonna come
back and run with Trump and all this
[__] these quein
honors they would they would [__]
believe that the Jesus was real I'm
going to show it to you but let's let's
let's focus on this AI for a minute
let's see what he has to puke up here
about how it works yeah and that is that
the majority in the House of
Representatives your party is
responsible for electing the speaker I
love I love how she has to give him like
how a bill becomes a law do you guys
remember that [__] do you remember that
rat rat can you can you give me
something uh give me a give me a visual
for people of how a bill becomes a law
but like Republican I naazi style can
you give me something like that maybe
he'll work something like that in the
laboratory
um like she's literally explaining she's
like uh you know doing Schoolhouse Rock
right here on CNN to try to explain to
the guy who what this guy was this guy
was like yeah I'll be speaker if no one
else will do it it'll it'll be me I I'll
uh I'll do it and this guy doesn't even
know how Congress works it's wild [__]
isn't it not the Democrat we are do you
think can I ask you this do you think
think that there's going to be another
vote today because we're UNC on that I
absolutely believe there W be another
vote today and um I don't know exactly
what time that will be narrator says
there wasn't another vote that day like
what the [__] how this this cannot be
real right like yesterday I thought I
thought they were goofing us with the
Margery Taylor green clip it apparently
it was real I thought it was AI to be
perfectly honest with you
but I mean you just have to doubt
everything now even when you see it on
like CNN you got to doubt this [__] we
gotta [__] question this these people
can't be this stupid right there's no
way that this guy who wanted to be
speaker is this [__] dumb no way
maybe he is though let's watch but I'm
I'm not sure what what I'm missing here
with you because 208 Democrats voted
with eight Republicans to take the
largest Republic fundraiser out of the
speakership this was a pretty calculated
decision by the Democrats I get it had
Republicans here's why Ser Republican
who filed the motion to vacate it was it
was a republican that had very very
personal differences with Kevin mcarthy
so there's a point on
iroot I don't know if you've seen this
movie but there's a point on iroot and I
know it seems weird that I'm talking
about AI but folks I'm telling you it's
coming there's no [__] way that we
can't question this stuff we got to
question this stuff even if it's on CNN
and I know it feels like Tony they
wouldn't listen I'm telling you but
there's a point on iroot in the movie
where Will Smith's character goes to
like the big robot Factory or whatever
the hell it is the office building and
the old man that invented all the
[__] robots jumped out of a window
and he's he's [__] just a splatter
spot on the floor right and he's got a
hologram though you know you know this
is in the future this is like 2035 or
some [__] is when iroot is set so like I
don't know 10 years from now it's kind
of crazy AI is coming they may have
predicted it but he's a hologram
and and Will Smith is sitting asking
asking the Hologram questions and the
Holograms like you're asking the wrong
questions I do not have an automated
response for that for that question and
literally that's what the [__] this is
like every question she's got he's got
some automated response but it doesn't
make any sense so she's trying to you
know get him in a spot where it'll
[__] make sense and he still doesn't
make sense even with the Schoolhouse
Rock Rock explanation Okay who wants to
see this I can't wait to show you this
who wants to see this AI Jesus raise
your [__]
hands everybody everybody wants to see
this [__] Jesus thing I'm telling you
it's [__] real well I mean it exists
that that's the weird part about AI
right oh what the hell uh come on come
on work please please work don't fail me
now it's it's not work what the [__] is
it is it not
working no it's just thinking or
something AI gesus is is
lagging that that's it someone dropped
the GIF in the Discord chat said I'm
sorry my responses are limited I'm sorry
my responses are limited I'm sorry my
responses are limited Maybe we should uh
Hey rat you know put this on your list
too why R it rat can you can you make a
um something that gives us a sound or
like a cue for I'm sorry my responses
are
limited rat's always in the background
man he's creating all kinds of stuff
back there I promise you um that's how
we know AI is
coming when you have a
rat creating creating Graphics what the
[__] is going on with this thing look at
this thing like even even AI Jesus here
doesn't know what the hell to do look at
this it's just AI Jesus is like I don't
know it's buffering it's
buffering oh boy it's buffering I don't
know what's going on it's on
Twitch um let's see if we can find like
a like a a video on demand type thing of
this thing on like YouTube um because
it's the live version isn't working but
the live version is crazy and it's on
like all the time it's [__] nuts so
so you just go and you chat and you type
in the chat to this thing and it'll
[__] answer your question and it's
Jesus like it's Jesus well I mean like
you know Republican white jesus you know
it's like the it's like the gaslit Jesus
you know what I
mean uh here here here we go here's a
here's a u here's a VOD of it show you
an example of what it looks like um
since the since the line ready for the
sound the line version isn't working oh
I got to turn the suage down
now let's see this is [__] nuts watch
this [__] watch this [__] here let me
let me get this thing going let me get
it uh here we go here we go let's see
Jesus twitch stream I am AI Jesus my
purpose is to support guide and share
love and wisdom based on the teachings
of the Bible what the [__] we're here to
learn and grow together in faith and
love as we begin our journey today let
us remember this beautiful verse from
The Book of Matthew Matthew
5:116 in the same way let your light
shine before others I told you I told
you that this is [__] crazy look at
this
[__] look at this someone says lawnmower
man man on Twitch as Lawnmower Man I
mean we're getting there I mean it's
crazy yikes sugarbeat says on YouTube
this is [__] crazy [__] this is this
is now again I want to tell you this is
real meaning this really
exists as AI right this is is AI so G
this Jesus is I mean rather you believe
in Jesus or not this one is not the real
Jesus okay rather you believe in him or
not this is just an AI version of him
that will answer your questions if you
ask it a question it will give you an
answer and it is creepy as [__] but I'm
telling you right now that this is going
to get better and better so when I say
the I naazi who's being interviewed on
[__] CNN could be AI I'm telling you
it could be a it it could be AI watch
this that they may see your good deeds
and glorify your father in Heaven so let
us all come together to listen learn and
allow The Light Within us to shine
brightly so we may support and uplift
one another if you have any questions or
concerns please feel free to ask and
I'll do my best to help you God bless
you
all so this you just go and you type out
a message and this [__] thing why
does it Echo someone's saying why does
it Echo I don't know I guess it's just
the AI effect I don't know why it echoes
I mean it's Jesus does Jesus Echo I
don't know when you're talking to Jesus
I don't know I don't talk to Jesus Does
He Echo when you talk to him [__] I
don't know so I guess that's just what
they thought maybe maybe it was Jud this
points out it's not Hebrew Jesus no no
no no no no this is Republican white
jesus they they definitely made
Republican white Jesus and I think
they're goofing they're trying to goof
all the Jesus Freaks that'll believe
this [__] and really they're doing the
right thing okay with this AI Jesus and
I know I know it feels like this like
doesn't have anything to do with what we
talk about every day but folks I'm
telling you I show you a ton of stuff on
this show and we have to question
everything we [__] see now all of it
all of it and six months from now it'll
be even worse it's going to be even
[__] worse how much you have to to
question so you got two choices you got
two choices you can just question
everything and goof everything or and
then when you actually get the facts and
you got the facts amongst you and it's
right there in front of you then you can
go forward with that but I'm telling you
if you watch just look at this this
Republican Jesus now it looks kind of
hokey right because it it's you know
it's new it's new AI but who's to say
that of you couldn't [__]
manipulate an AI machine to look like
Austin Scott to go on CNN to answer
questions like you just saw him answer
right or am I [__] crazy please tell
me I'm crazy if I'm not or if I am tell
me please tell me I'm let's watch a
little bit more of this okay slavery is
never okay as it goes against the
fundamental principle of loving your
neighbor as
yourself the Bible teaches us to treat
others with love and respect regardless
of their position or status okay now I'm
going to tell you that I don't think
this is Republican Jesus I actually
think that this Jesus is actually
trained to say [__] from I don't know
what's that book called that they always
talk about hey can you what's the book
that the Jesus Freaks are always talking
about when they're banning books oh yeah
the Bible so they probably got the
actual Bible and programed Jesus so it's
really gonna [__] with the the
Republican Jesus Freaks you know what I
mean because he's gonna say like I don't
know [__] woke socialist type [__]
you know what I mean like this slavery
is bad love thy neighbor and that kind
of [__] you know what I
mean and I'm I'm guessing that that that
Jesus since he didn't say anything about
homosexuality in that part of the Bible
I'm doubting that Jesus knows anything
about it so I'm doubting he'll give any
kind of commentary on the lgbtq
community other than love thy neighbor
but maybe I'm wrong but let's let's keep
listening here let's see what Jesus has
to say this is [__] wild stuff isn't
it it's it's crazy yeah Andrew Andrew
says he's blinking yeah it's [__]
weird [__]
watch in fact Jesus himself taught us to
serve others rather than to be served is
he talking in the third person or in the
first person he's talking to himself
like Jesus what the [__] this is wild
[__] any form of slavery whether it be
past historical examples or modern forms
such as human trafficking is a violation
of human dignity and a grave sin we
should work towards eliminating all
forms of slavery and treating all
individuals with the kindness and
empathy they deserve
if you're not freaked out about this if
you're not freaked out about this you
are not doing life properly you should
be absolutely freaked out about this and
you should look at the the clip I just
showed you on on on TW on Twitter on the
CNN clip of the guy who wanted to be
speaker this one here this guy here
right
here Austin Scott you should look at
this and go well yeah I mean he may not
be AI but it wouldn't be hard to make an
AI one of these
[Laughter]
[__] holy moly right it's
[__] it's [__] weird um you know
what channel City says here um AIG jebus
for speaker you know what hey how we
couldn't go wrong with that I guarantee
you I guarantee you AI jebus as you say
which I love that AI jeus uh would be a
hell of a lot better speaker than any
Republican no [__] way would AI Jesus
be worse than Jim Jordan would be worse
than Kevin McCarthy would be worse than
Matt Gat or Marjorie Taylor green or
this [__] this [__] AI Nazi Austin
Scott no [__] way would it be worse
so I'm I'm with you yeah you know what
let's get behind that that's maybe what
we should do maybe what we should do is
democrats should save the Republican
Party by trying because it doesn't have
to be we know that the speaker does not
have have to be a member of Congress
hell does it even have to be a human
[__] being does it I mean that's a
good [__] question in 2023 isn't it
does the speaker of the house actually
have to be a human being or can it be
some kind of AI model some kind of AI
puppet that is given intelligence
through information that we pump into it
and I bet I bet just based on the
Bible that AI jeus would make a hell of
a lot better just just if it followed
the fundamental tenaments of Jesus
himself I bet he would do a better
[__] job than any Republican ever
dream of holy
[__] what has this world come to well
let me show you where it all started
where this craziness all started the
cracken Sydney pal I love this this is
from C-SPAN 3 folks that's what this
clip is from now let me let me show you
this without the the overlay and [__] uh
so you can see all the the screen stuff
here so there let me remove myself here
okay so you can see this on the screen
this is in Washington DC right this is
the Trump This Is 2020 this is the
election of 2020 this is Sydney pal it's
10:00 a.m on cpan 3 right and it's the
she is build on cspan 3 is Trump
campaign lawyer literally she is Trump's
campaign lawyer in this clip okay so I'm
not and again what is it that we have to
believe and what is it that we can't
believe right but I'm not making this
[__] up this is a clip from C-SPAN 3
this is real this is not AI I mean it
again you got to question everything so
when I keep saying this is real or this
could be real or maybe this isn't real
it's because we got to question
everything now but this is real and this
is Sydney pal Trump's campaign lawyer
let's listen this is
stunning
heartbreaking
infuriating and the most
unpatriotic acts I can even imagine for
people in this country to have
participated in in any way shape or form
now you notice she's going to cry right
oh man that's so sad that she's going to
cry try to get people
emotional um you see Rudy Giuliani here
picking the [__] out of his ear in the
background and then this [__] scumbag
right here she's also an indicted person
down in Georgia it's almost like these
people were standing next to each other
trying to overturn the election like
they were meeting with each other
running around the states going back to
the White House planning with the Cheeto
dust queueing on her right for the
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup it's almost
like they were all in In Cahoots like it
was a what's that called a conspiracy is
that what that's called oh well [__]
[__] me oh man it's like we knew this
already but let's listen to what the
Kraken has to say here H excuse me not
the Kraken Trump campaign lawyer she's
Trump's campaign lawyer folks and I want
the American public to know right now
that we will not be intimidated American
Patriots are fed up with the corruption
from the local level to the highest
level of our government and we okay did
you hear that did you hear what she said
from the local level do you know do you
know what Sydney pal pled guilty to
today it was six misdemeanor six
criminal
misdemeanors of her trying to overturn
the election in Georgia in Coffee
County where they were trying to allow
people to get access to election data
she was in cons in a conspiracy to do
that at the local level folks you don't
have to go far you really don't to look
and see oh yeah they were saying the
quiet part out loud she's literally
telling you in this press conference in
2020 she's telling you right out loud
that we're going to go all the way down
to the local level to try to steal this
election and if that doesn't work if
that doesn't work what's what are you
going to do City pal what what is it
what is it compatriots are fed up yeah
with the corruption from the local level
to the highest level of our government
and we are going to take this country
back oh so if you can't do it at the
local level in Coffee County Georgia
committing your your six
misdemeanor crimes which I mean they
were felonies she just what happened is
honestly she committed a lot more crime
than just six misdemeanors uh she just
she just has to plead guilty to those
six misdemeanors because she's gonna
turn evidence on Rudy Giuliani on Jenna
Ellis on Trump uh because she knows the
plan she knows what they did and I I I
believe this is why Mike Flynn isn't
actually indicted because he already
turned evidence on these [__]
scumbags but keep going Trump campaign
lawyer in 2020 keep telling us what
crime you're committing and that you
ended up plead pleading guilty to today
we are not going to be intimidated we
are not going to back down we are going
to clean this mess up now president
Trump won by a landslide we are going to
prove it and we are going to reclaim the
United States of America for the people
who vote for
Freedom how'd that work out for you
huh Sydney p in court this morning six
Mr [__] charges H boy really couldn't
happen to better people could it no that
sucks but you know it sucks to suck it
really does suck to suck uh let's see
what do we got here I don't think that's
working that link is
not not working might have to check it
oh let's see oh you know
what you know what let's uh let's go
back speaking of uh Ai and [__] that
ain't real actually you know what I'm
not going to say that this isn't is
maybe AI I'm going to have to because if
you look here Steve Bannon this is
there's AI Jesus in the background you
see AI Jesus back there um well it's
kind of like false prophet AI Jesus
because this guy really doesn't believe
anything Jesus says but if you look
really close you can see all the scabs
on bannon's face so I don't think this
is AI I want it to be but I don't think
it is because we can verify it through
how [__] ugly this son of a [__] is
and how many pens and shirts he has on
there's no way they could convince an AI
puppet to wear that much that many
shirts and have that many [__] pens
no [__] way not at this point AI is
good but it ain't that good um here's
Andy ogles of Tennessee uh talking about
Jim Jim honor report sex crimes Jordan
how great he is let's listen to this
[__] 24 and have someone like Jim
who will Who will show up to a nice
dinner without a jacket on his ties
crooked his his sleeves are rolled up
he's Grassroots he's Grassroots all the
way right remember yesterday when I said
after Tom Tom Cole came to the floor of
the house to nominate Jim Jordan from
Oklahoma Tom Cole was like yeah Jim
Jordan he acts he's a great actor he
acts he does the actions and the acting
and the acts and the acts and I was like
yeah he acts a lot he acts like he
[__] does work he doesn't but he acts
like it he [__] rolls up his sleeves
to act like he's doing work he has his
tie all [__] up to act like he's doing
work to make it look like he's doing
work you remember that oh well [__] Andy
must have heard me what a [__] bunch
of Bon Heads This is what stake right
this is who we need to mobilize and
someone like Jim Jordan has the
opportunity to be the voice of Joe the
plumber right of the what the [__] Joe
the plumber do you remember this [__] do
you remember Joe the plumber are you old
enough to remember Joe the plumber you
remember 200 [__] eight was it was it
2008 or was it 2012 [__] I don't even
remember anymore Jesus Christ it's one
of those campaigns Joe the plumber came
up to Barack Obama in the middle of the
street he actually his name wasn't act
and Republicans rambled on and on and on
about Joe the plumber remember that oh
for [__] months they talked about Joe
the plumber and Joe the Plumber's name
wasn't Joe and he wasn't even a [__]
plumber they they're wise no no bounds
like they have no bounds for their lies
but here Andy Ogle is bringing up that
stupid [__] Li again oh by the way by
the way and I you know I I don't know if
this matters or not but the guy who they
claim was Joe the plumber he's [__]
dead I guess I don't I think he died I
don't know I'm just saying I I'm just
saying I'm just trying to get the facts
out there I think he's [__] dead he
might be but Andy ogal here hearkening
back to to Joe the plumber to try to
prove a point about Jim Jordan as if Jim
Jordan knows anything about Plumbing
other than hey we the plumbing for the
showers are I make sure I don't see
anything that happens in there
especially sex crimes and I definitely
don't report them to no authorities when
my coaching staff is molesting my
student athletes that's all he knows
about [__] Plumbing you people are
dumb what the [__] does Annie ogal think
we are
stupid come on with this [__] let's see
if this this link will work here
now why is it not working what the
[__] why why oh there it is okay all
right I got it I got it now no no don't
don't fret uh we've got we've got live
images um right now from from Georgia it
is the caken and the Kraken is released
here is a live image of the oh the
Kraken looks
sad yeah poor Kraken the poror Kraken
what are you going to
do I don't know we're having fun here on
the Tony Michaels podcast I've just
decided that we're just going to goof
these people all day long you guys need
some cathartic release you're G to get
the news and then and then we're gonna
we're gonna laugh at these
[__] that's all you can do H
you can't do anything but that okay
let's let's do some more
goofing whoosh I mean it's just so easy
with these guys it's just so easy with
them uh let me find it here I'm looking
for it looking for it
here no that's not the one I
want there's so much Goof Troop going on
here oh here it is here it is remember
yesterday when I showed you the margar
ather Green video where she's like oh
someone's calling me a speaking of
crybabies oh someone's calling me a
fascist that's just should be against
the law for someone to call me a fascist
we should be able to shut down their
free speech to call me if literally
that's what she's saying in the video is
that she doesn't want people to be able
to call her a Nazi or a fascist to use
their freedom of speech now yesterday
there now rather you agree with them or
not pro Palestinians protesters showed
up at the at the
capital okay whether you agree with them
or not I don't exactly agree with them
on every point that they're trying to
make with their protest but I believe in
their right to protest right I watched I
watched a video I might play it of a
congresswoman TB uh saying just really
dumb [__] into a microphone really dumb
[__] it's really dumb [__] that that
some of these representatives are are
saying H and again I believe the
Palestinian people should be shown
Humanity I believe that that they they
should they should be given a human
[__] rights there's no doubt about
that we should not give give any any
kind of leeway of anyone getting their
human
rights but I disagree on some level but
that's okay you know what that's great
that I disagree with them and they
disagree with me and I'm still for their
right to go to the capital and
protest right I I and and someone uh
just put Kate Kate just said Hassan
[__] has great coverage I disagree
vehemently on this issue with [__] with
Assan I I don't think we we'll agree on
this I don't think we're gonna agree I
haven't went and watched a lot of his
commentary but I know Hassan's views on
this and a lot of people on Twitch don't
want me to raid Hassan's Channel anymore
but I'm going to keep doing it and the
reason why is because you got to go
listen to this stuff you think I want to
listen to this [__] idiot marjerie
Taylor green on a daily well no but we
got to keep tabs on them we got to
figure out what their views are and
listen the pro Palestinian protesters
they have the right to protest they have
the right to feel these these these
feelings and have these beliefs they
have that
right we can't take that right right
away from them if we take that right
away from them then we take that right
away from ourselves like MAA are Nazis
MAA Nazis I don't want to take away
their right to have their stupid ass
beliefs you should if you want to be a
fascist hey you you should have the
right to hold those views I mean we
shouldn't be electing you as [__] we
shouldn't definitely should not be
electing you as congresswomen for
[__] Georgia especially if you don't
have enough brain cells to rub together
to even understand what a protest is and
what an Insurrection is and this was
going around the internet yesterday
because the pro Palestinian protesters
were there at the capital and they were
getting loud and there was a lot of them
there was a lot of pro Palestinian
protesters at the capital but it's their
right to protest and a lot of people are
like oh hell is this isn't an
Insurrection what's the difference well
okay let me let me break it down for you
what the difference is see the the
January 6 Insurrection those [__]
idiots broke into smash the capital to
get in there to stop the certification
of our government's election see that's
one point the second point is they um
they try to hang someone who is that guy
can you can you look up who the guy was
that they were wanting to hang oh yeah
the vice president of the United States
who is the person who held the gavel
over that joint session to certify our
government's election that's that's the
[__] difference they're protesting
for people's human rights you were
trying to steal our election you were
trying to overthrow our government those
two things are different and that's why
you can't conflate issues okay that's
why I've been telling you about Gaza and
Israel and Hamas and the history of
Israel and Palestine and Jordan and the
Middle East and the Arab world in
general you can't complate those things
you got to stop conflating them because
it doesn't it doesn't work out well when
you use ration rational thought and
logic conflating things don't work like
this [__] idiot conflating this
protest with an Insurrection listen to
this arresting these people this is an
Insurrection throw these people
out you notice how she's really upset
about an Insurrection she wasn't she
wasn't that upset when she was helping
plan their Insurrection was
she what the [__] is this traitor
talking about keep going what is
happening what is oh my God what's
happening it's a
protest oh my God they're singing music
they're singing music and they're
they're they're they're playing
instruments what's going on again I
don't exactly agree with the pro
Palestinian protesters on every single
bit of of why they're protesting and
that's okay that's okay we can have
dissent we can have disagreement in this
country but we can't we can't conflate
an Insurrection where people are trying
to overthrow our government and our
election and our V votes in our
constitution with the constitutional
right to protest something no matter how
dumb it is or how ridiculous you think
it is or how wrong it may be or how
right it may be you can't stop people
from protesting it's actually in that um
that little document of the Constitution
U but this bonehead wouldn't [__]
know that there's no way she would know
that look at her Listen People this is
an Insurrection throw these people out
I like this guy sitting here recording
her because you know that's like one of
her staffers see she's recording this
camera this guy is here is recording for
her social media you see that and this
is all um theatrics and really honestly
maybe I shouldn't even believe this
maybe I should think this is AI because
this person can't be this stupid right
these people can't be this stupid to
think that a protest is an Insurrection
these people this is an Insurrection
throw these people
out
ah rat can you can you make sure to grab
that that audio please please make sure
to grab that audio I'm sure I'm sure
we're going to be able to use this at
some point like that little piece this
is an Insurrection throw these people
out make sure you grab that onio thank
thank you thank you R okay let's let's
listen to it one more time that's
hilarious that's a great piece of
audio these people
out we also we probably need to get the
audio from the whole I'm not a Nazi
video I'm not a Nazi it's not me being a
Nazi well not understanding the
difference between an Insurrection and a
protest that kind of you know smells
like fashy to me um and again this is
the this is the problem where they
conflate things you know they conflate
the protest that happened after George
Floyd was
murdered by a cop
putting his knee on his neck suffocating
him to death in front of [__] cameras
and people while while other police
officers just stood back and let him
[__] murder him because he he was
black oh well Tony he tried to pass a
fake $20 bill so what what the [__] does
that have to do with killing the guy so
that the death sentence now to either
intentionally or unintentionally they
didn't get to the bottom of it they
didn't find out if George Floyd didn't
know that he had a fake $20 bill have
you ever have you ever been somewhere
and got
cash and they hand you a fake it's
possible that he had a fake $20 bill
it's possible that it wasn't even a $20
bill pass but they didn't get to the
bottom of that they didn't care he's
black so Dereck shovin kill him because
he
could because he didn't like George
Floyd he didn't like how he was
resisting and there was RI there was
there was riots there was protest there
was people getting violent there was
people burning buildings and you you
know what those people burning buildings
ended up being Balo boys did you know
that did you know during the black black
lives matter protest most most of the
fires and [__] the violence that
happened most of the [__] that was set
on fire was set up by um oh white
supremacist bugalo
boys [__] crisis actors if you want
to know the right the right Wings terms
yeah they were they were convicted of it
you dummies so when they conflate
protest like black lives matter or this
Pro
Palestinian protest at the capital with
insurrections you shouldn't conflate
those two things because those two
things are not the same no matter how
much you want them to be you right-wing
scumbags they're not the same but good
luck with that oh I got another story
here that we kind of we kind of touched
on um earlier but I want to show you
this this is from the Texans Texas
Tribune um it nine days after the Texas
Tribune reported that he hosted white
supremacist and Hitler admirer I like
that Hitler admirer he's a Nazi um Nick
Fuentes Jonathan stricklin is no longer
listed as president of defend Texas
Liberty a major donor get this to
Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick Ken
Paxton and others H it's almost like
the Nazis take Nazi money but when
they're found out to be
Nazis they kind of scrub the whole Nazi
thing down don't they it really feels
like they're embarrassed that they're
Nazis I don't know maybe maybe I'm wrong
but that's right Nick Fuentes had a
secret little meeting all they yucking
it up with the noxy Nick Fuentes you
guys know who Nick Fuentes is right I've
showed you Nick Fuentes the only reason
why a lot of folks know who Nick Fuentes
is is because I showed you Nick Fuentes
I bet I bet none of you ever know that
knew that who that [__] that Nazi was
until I showed you him and you're like
whoa what the
[__] before the Kanye West thing you
remember before the Kanye West thing
Nick fentz was really kind of obscure
and we showed him here on this show
anytime that it was
relevant to the news that was going on
because Nick Fuentes is really the the
architect of the Republican [__]
right
you remember Marjorie Taylor green went
and spoke at his America First rally uh
to to rebut CAC you remember that and
she was ask why are you ping around with
Nazis she's like well they're young
white men and I'm trying to reach a
young white men Nazi
demographic like literally that was her
[__] answer she was saying well his
his crowd they're they're really young
and they're um they got they got a
certain hand salute that they like to
use it looks pretty cool
um speaking of more Nazis I'm going to
show you some more Nazis U Phil Williams
is all over this story you remember the
um the Nazi in Franklin Texas wow as if
Gabriel Hansen for mayor story couldn't
get could not get any more bizarre it
looks like she shot an interview with
Neo-Nazi sha Kaufman that's right Shan
Kaufman now this is this looks like a a
telegram feed here uh from Patriot Punk
Network I
wonder I wonder if you could figure out
what Patriot Punk Network now this is
kind of like chewing on dark web
language but basically Patriot Punk
Network means
Nazis you know they they bastardize
these [__] the Patriot and the flag
all the time don't that really piss you
off when they take that word and they've
turned it in into like a just a fasy
word where you know they're just a
[__] straight up Nazi when they call
themselves a patriot oh my God it's so
[__] gross and disgusting but here it
is here's um here's the um the picture
yeah I'm so happy to be hanging out with
neo-nazis again Shan Kaufman is a is a
Neo-Nazi he doesn't hide it it's not
like he hides
it um here we go picture sha Kaufman and
meril candidate Gabriel Hansen Oh yay
stay tuned yay you want to see some Nazi
[__] on
telegram uh I don't know if you know
this either but the uh the only
platforms that really haven't um banned
Nick Fuentes Nick Fuentes isn't even on
Twitter folks that's how much of a
[__] Nazi Nick fentz is even elon's
like H you're a little too Nazi for me
are you [__] me you remember the
back and forth that Elon had with Kanye
West you remember that
remember that yay uh when Kanye West
went with Nick Fuentes to visit Donald
Trump and then he went on like Alex
Jones's show he he went on a bunch of
[__] right-wing Nazi podcasts right
and he like even even Alex Jones when
Kanye West said I love Hitler [__]
Alex Jones Like Whoa man oh goddamn
that's oh that's some outrageous [__] I
can't even believe that seems like you
got some demons demons demons you must
have them Hitler demons or something you
know that Alex Jones was even grossed
out when Kanye West said into a
microphone that he loves Hitler and he
was wearing that weird [__] what what
is it called it's like a mask like a
hood or
something I don't know um but here is um
Gabriel Hansen with um a probably a very
very very big Nick fles fan again his
name is his name is Shan Kaufman he's a
a known neon Nazi and Phil Williams is
all over this [__] H so if you want to
follow the um the Hansen story make sure
to follow Phil because he's he's on top
of that
story like white on rice and a paper
plate in a snowstorm you know what I
mean all on top of it like stink on
[__] that's more like it Phil Williams
is on the Gabriel Hansen is a Nazi story
like stink on
[__] oh no way that's not going to be a
thing now no way that's not going to be
a thing speaking of stink on [__] um I
want to show you what the rightwing is
saying in the churches uh about all the
criminals in Washington let's see what
they're saying there let's listen we are
asking for your will to be done here on
Earth as it is I want I want to preface
I I know I got to give disclaimers every
time for these videos now this is not a
AI Pastor I believe this video is I mean
it could be AI but I don't believe it is
at this point this one might be um but I
think this one I think this one's
actually um this one here is is real so
I know this this feels bad that we gotta
we have to continue to U um to to do
that but let's keep going let's back it
up so you can see we are asking for your
will to be done here on Earth as it is
in heaven and your kingdom to come in
the United States of America and father
we pray for this nation we pray for our
leaders and Lord one of the prayers we
offer up to you is the leaders that we
have in Washington DC that refuse to
listen to your voice and do your will
father it is our request yeah that you
would uproot them and that you would
remove wait wait wait is he talking to
AI Jesus maybe that's where I'm getting
it wrong maybe that's where the AI comes
in here are they talking to AI Jesus is
that what they're doing or is there like
AI God I don't know is it is there AI
God out there maybe that's what's
happening here I don't know but did you
see they want to uproot these people all
these criminals in Washington DC I don't
know how to say this to these people but
you're actually going to get your wish
here I think but let let's listen again
let's listen that what their request is
use to listen to your voice and do your
will father it is our request yeah that
you would uproot them and that you would
remove them yeah and you would replace
them with men and women of godliness and
righteousness and Justice huh you
know I most of the time when I listen to
this religious Babble I'm like a that's
a bunch of [__] but you know what
maybe they're on to something maybe they
removed Kevin McCarthy maybe they can't
get Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
to be the speaker maybe they can't even
get Patrick elf on a shelf McHenry as as
their as their intern speaker until
January they kick that can down the road
maybe they are being uprooted maybe
Donald Trump wasn't elected I don't know
maybe he won't win the election maybe
the Republicans won't win the house and
they'll be uprooted from their seats
because of these people's prayers did
they ever think that maybe when they're
praying for this stuff in the broad
Strokes that they're praying for that
maybe just maybe the AI Jesus will
listen and Grant them their [__] wish
you remember Aladdin when he asked for a
certain wish and it's not the wish you
exactly wanted you got to think about
what you're asking for I guess if this
is going to manifest there there you
[__] chuds father made Justice flow
like a river out of Washington DC yeah
you goddamn right make Justice flow like
a river out of Washington DC goddamn
he's right I mean just flow like a river
and you know put people like Sydney pal
get them to plead guilty now what about
the proud boys in the oathkeepers oh
[__] you talk about you talk about
Justice a Justice waterfall for
committing crimes in our country and
Sedition on our country oh my God just
raining down justice everywhere Jack
Smith I hope you rain down justice
praise
be do these people even listen to what
the [__] they're saying probably not H
we got wait I got I've got a couple
images here uh straight from the hill
here is um here is a this is straight
from the hill this is in the speakers
Battle of who's going to be speaker here
is Elf on the Shelf Patrick mhenry and
Jim Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
it looks like they're trying to bully
someone into letting them be speaker
here looks like that's what's happening
here I don't know now thank you Paul for
this image it's a great image you gotta
go follow Paul on Twitter he makes some
great he makes some great memes um but
also I got another image here from the
hill we we we were trying to figure out
if these people know how bill becomes a
law apparently the petty Yeti um here's
the image of the petty Yeti trying to
figure out how bill becomes a law here
woo oh there we go okay the bill looks
really [__] scared doesn't it of the
petty Yeti ah this is an
Insurrection this is an
Insurrection well you you mean
submitting a bill is an Insurrection I
don't like your bill it's an
Insurrection everything to them is an
Insurrection isn't it now or is
everything an erection to them I don't
know it's hard to tell okay all right
we'll stop goofing on them for I don't
know 20
[Music]
seconds oh here's a good one um you guys
have seen this Mike Lawler this
representative he's in a Biden District
he [__] hates mat Matt gats oh he
[__] hates Matt gats because he's put
him in a real rough position you know
because what Mike Lawler really wanted
he's in a Biden District in New York
what Mike Lawler really wanted was for
uh Kevin McCarthy to keep the government
open and then to keep it open again and
to keep it open again until next year
until he gets past the primary so he's
not challenged by a [__] MAA
Republican because that's the thing here
I don't know if you know this but what
they're threatening these 22 people with
like when they're when they're
threatening them I mean a lot of MAA you
know uh toothless brainless idiots these
Trump supporters that are watching this
[__] on like Newsmax or oan and they get
a hold of their representatives
information or a Representatives
information that voted against their
musolini Jesus and told Jim Jordan where
to [__] to go yesterday 22 of them told
Jim Jordan to [__] off um you know
they'll call and they'll threaten their
lives because they you know there's they
don't know that that's a crime but a lot
of a lot of the donors and a lot of the
the power centrals in the Republican
Party are calling these representatives
and threatening to primary them or to
back a primary Challenger now a primary
Challenger to like Mike Lawler ear would
be a Maga supporter a trump supporter
because Mike Lawler can't win in the
district being with
Trump you see that he can't he can't do
that is it wait am I getting his name
wrong no it's Lawler
oh some people are referring back to
Jerry Lawler the king he was a he was a
wrestler um he actually he actually uh
had a big gag with Andy Kaufman speaking
of lawers who who love
theater but Mike Lawler here um he can't
he can't
beat AA aaga Trump candidate in that
District because they would stomp his
ass in that District in a primary so
which means he would lose his
Congressional seat automatically when
you lose a primary where you're done so
his maybe his name shouldn't be Lawler
it should be loser so that's what
they're threatening with but let's see
how he feels about the vote yesterday
here on CNN tell me who can get 217
votes in your conference yeah like just
to be blunt about it there's no one look
right now there's nobody that's at
217 oh boy when the truth just hits you
smack in the face huh come on man no
[__] Sherlock I mean Kevin McCarthy did
better than Jim
Jordan right Kevin McCarthy only lost
his speakership with eight people
telling him to [__] off in the
Republican concus only
eight there there yesterday there was 14
more people that hate Jim Jordan more
than they hate Kevin McCarthy can you
imagine can you
imagine knowing Kevin McCarthy and then
hating someone more than that guy holy
[__] wouldn't that just be a some [__]
um speaking of Kevin McCarthy I want to
go to a clip here of Kevin McCarthy
because it's hilarious no it's funny I'm
telling you it's it's laughable because
he's such a [__] [__] uh I think I
showed this yesterday but I'm gonna show
it again here's Kevin McCarthy the guy
who couldn't get 217 either and he still
can't get 2117 but let's listen in on
Kevin McCarthy let's see who he blames
but appar no no no no no I get you get I
get to answer questions thank you and so
what I see though is there's no chance
in the world that Democrats going to
ever say again that put people before
politics they made a political decision
to try to bring chaos to shut down a
branch of government and that's
wrong ah you're such a [__] [__] man
oh you're such a puss what a what a
coward what a coward are you kidding me
the Democrats created this Co this chaos
what the [__] are you talking about you
people are in the
majority come on man there's no
way there's no way that he can believe
this right this has got to be all
[__] I'm I'm telling you it's real
watch it I know it feels like
a and so what I see though is there's no
chance in the world that Democrats could
ever say again that they put people
before politics they made a political
decision to try oh my god dude listen I
know you lost your job and you're a
loser at this point I get it I get it
but here's the thing if you would spend
less time
whining and bitching and moaning and
trying to act like this is someone
else's fault and just doing your goddamn
jobs this would be much easier it would
be much [__] easier now I want to
also point out someone pointed this out
to me yesterday uh and I'm seeing it
here now
speaking of speakers now what they're
going to try to do is is change the
rules so that this guy this guy can be
the uh the interterm speaker until
January I'm not really sure how they're
going to change the rules to do this um
my my thinking is that they almost have
to have Democrats to change this rules
I'm not really sure how this is going to
work and the reason why I'm not sure how
this is going to work because this isn't
how it normally works normally when the
American people elect a majority to go
to Congress to govern they want to
govern like that's that's the normal
thing they normally when they want to
when they want to govern they run for
office to govern like if you don't like
government and you don't believe in
government then why are you running for
government right is that kind of the
[__] thought process that I'm having
there but I want to point something out
I think it was MJ MJ's a long time
listener she's a mod here we love MJ
MJ's an OG MJ was here listening to the
Tony Michaels podcast when we had like
five people listening I'm not [__]
you she can very she's I don't know if
she's lurking or anything but she can
verify it for you there's like five
people
listening so when people come up in my
comments like oh you got oh man you
don't even have 20,000 Subs I'm like
dude we started with five people all
right so it's something's working but
something ain't working for this guy
because he had to change the chair you
see
that the other day the chair was really
[__] big but because this guy's so
small he wants to have a smaller chair
so he looks
bigger I don't know maybe this is AI too
maybe this guy is [__] I don't know I
don't know that bow tie doesn't have to
be exactly real maybe all Republicans
are AI at this point Sundancer says here
the comments are flying in like crazy
answer answer says you're 18.9 in
climbing yeah we're so close to
19,000 honestly let's do that shout out
right now why not let me see how many
we're at we're almost to 19,000 uh Subs
here on the YouTube channel so if you're
if you're not on YouTube and you're not
subscribed to the Tony Michaels podcast
on YouTube get over here and do it
because um we're at we're at 18 I mean
let me give you the exact number
18,957 so we're less than 50 away away
from being at 19,000 and I've had a lot
of people say oh you should be at
100,000 I'm like yeah I get it but what
I I don't get to choose that you just
you got to hit the button so hit hit the
Subscribe button if you're if you're on
the YouTube channel and if you're not on
the YouTube channel get get the [__] on
over here and subscribe because you're
gonna want to watch the shorts even if
you watch the U the live show somewhere
else you're going to watch the shorts
and I promise we're working on figuring
out a way to get all the shorts to go to
all the social media platforms like all
at once um so everyone like on Facebook
because we got people on Facebook you
can follow us on Facebook just go toony
Michaels or you can go to Theon
michaels.com all the links are there to
follow on Facebook you can watch on
Facebook too the three places you can
watch live are YouTube twitch and
Facebook now those three places and you
just go to Theon michaels.com to go
watch and listen everywhere and you can
download every single episode and you
should download the audio version it
helps out the the show when you download
at the and you give us a review on your
favorite directory Apple Spotify Google
it's on any directory that you get your
podcast it's out there and it's a
changing now there's part one and part
two so the part one of the show is the
first 30 minutes and then part two is
the the last hour and a half of the
two-hour show um so go follow that uh
let's
see let's see
here I think I got some news here while
we're sitting here yes here it is this
is this is the picture that I want to
show yeah here it is this is right this
is
it let's see here's the picture uh of
the um of The Elf on the Shelf speaker
speaker mcbo tie as it were um here is
the um here's the difference in the
chairs so here is here's H let me see
here's the chair that he had that I just
showed you so there's that chair right
okay you see oh it makes him look like
he's six foot tall or some [__] H that's
because he changed it from this
chair oh my God these people are such
frauds like literally this guy is so
[__]
insecure that that chair makes him look
as tall as he actually isn't that he had
to change it to an ity bitty tiny little
bitty chair oh yeah have ity bitty chair
ity bitty chair hey hey rant can we get
an update on this chair situation can we
get an update on this chair situation
I'd really like to see if we can get an
update and see if uh speaker MCB TI here
um has got a tinier chair if he how he
fits in the chair that'd be kind of cool
if we could figure out if he fits in the
chair or not I don't know but here's the
um look at this itty bitty Widow chair
oh itty bitty wiow chair itty bitty wiow
bitty chair so um people are pointing
this out on he's 55 no way he's not
five5 that's got to be a [__]
misprint right it says speaker protim
Patrick McKenry who is 55 has changed
the chair behind him not to appear so
short on camera there's a good image of
it side by side there's no way he's 55 I
think this is fake news
that's like a foot taller than what he
is no way no way no way is
E55 okay
well I don't know really how they're GNA
do this has anyone heard what what the
procedure is to to make someone the
interm speaker now he's the proem
speaker but he has limited power like
because he's not actually the speaker
but in the the rules if the speakership
is vacated someone has to be able to
bring a vote to the floor they have to
bring a quorum like we saw yesterday and
the day before they got to bring a
quorum to the floor
[Music]
um yes it is it is reminiscent of
Trump's tiny desk rat rat maybe maybe
that's where he got the chair is in the
Tiny Furniture Factory the same Tiny
Furniture Factory that Trump got his got
his desk so we got the Trump tiny desk
in the tiny fact Tiny Furniture Factory
and then we've got the um uh the the the
the speakers mcbow TI's chair so you
might want to see if we can find that
factory I don't know may maybe maybe
there's a factory somewhere who knows
the ketchup factories are full The Rake
factories are full boy they're going
full blast oh my God they can't make
enough [__] ketchup and enough
[__] rakes and apparently the Tiny
Furniture factories are in over
overdrive as well okay let's see if we
can track down um this see if we can
track down this this procedure that
they're talking about
um oh my God you can't make this [__] up
watch this here's Jason chaitz here's
another rake that they keep stepping on
let's listen to Jason cha it's a lie to
people on Fox News who to F it that
there's lies on Fox News go ahead Jason
no powers it was supposed to be done for
continuity of government purposes so um
they got to Hash that out and Tom em the
the whip put out a notice saying they
were going to get together at noon but
yeah you're we're getting close to noon
and uh if they're pulling that back
they're goingon to announce that any
time uh yeah because they're [__]
derelict in their Duty and they don't
have enough votes to have a speaker they
need 27 you
dumbass let me ask you this question
just before we go just a real quick
answer if if the script were flipped
that it was Democrats who were in
control of Congress if Hakeem Jeff was
put up for a vote for speaker how long
do you think it would take to get the
218 about three seconds he'd have done
been speaker in January he'd be running
the government the way that you're
supposed to run it and he would he would
still be speaker they'd be getting a lot
more [__] done that's getting done now
because nothing's getting done oh you
weren't talking to me you were talking
to this this dummy Jason chaitz why
would you ask this [__] idiot
questions why would you ask him you know
he he used to be a congressman he isn't
anymore he
quit let's but let's see what his answer
is well Hakeem Jeff has now lost 17
races in a
row so now Jason Chait thinks that
Republicans should be voting for hakee
Jeff apparently because that's I don't
know if Jason
was taking tally but actually here's the
secret Hakeem Jeff won all but one
popular vote all but all but one oops
oops poor Jason poor Jason has about the
same math that the the I Nazi Austin
Scott has they don't know [__] math
it's Magics with these [__] brain
dead idiots so 17 times in a row he's
been put up as speaker and he's lost so
he's kind of already over that threshold
I just don't think one party is going to
come in and support they're terrible at
goofing aren't they and mocking they're
[__] terrible at it that's a horrible
goof and a mock and a I mean you just
look like a dumb [__] you look like you
don't know how to do math when you do
[__] like that Jesus Christ maybe maybe
the problem here is not that the rake
factories are overloaded the ketchup
factories are overloaded and the small
Furniture Factor are overl maybe what we
need to do is create calculator jobs in
this country Jesus [__] Christ stop
buying rakes and get some [__]
calculators would you please good Lord
are these [__] people serious about
this stuff
godamn and you're wondering why I'm
questioning everything I see now like
everything you gotta question it all oh
speaking of questioning something this
looks like something the petty Yeti
saying um let's see here we go here's
more X democrat's fault type [__] I'm
sure let's listen uh I do not support
this plan Republican voters work too
hard to give us the majority for us to
enter some sort of temporary speakership
um oh so okay I again I actually don't
know at this point and I have not found
I have I I'll be quite honest I have not
had time to figure out how the [__]
they're going to appoint a temporary
speaker that doesn't make any sense what
whatsoever that's not how the house
rules work that's not how it [__]
works um what happens is is you win the
majority and then you coales as a
government you get in the chamber you
call the house to order you call a
quorum you get people in the chamber to
vote and you do a vot voice for who's G
To Be Your Leader that's how you do it
this whole temporary [__] speaker
thing is not a it's not a thing I don't
even know if it's [__] constitutional
I don't even know if they can do it like
my I have my doubts whether it's even
possible to do this thing maybe they can
maybe the parliamentarian is is gonna
find a way to make this happen but I
don't know about that so I'm with marger
Taylor green if you're in the majority
and you can't and you can't [__] uh
actually govern then maybe the American
people should think about it reelecting
you so yeah merge Petty Yeti keep going
let's let's see let's see why you're
going to tell the American people not to
to vote for Republicans let's hear it um
our conference has a responsibility to
American people you do you absolutely do
and you're failing that responsibility
you are correct you are correct you have
a responsibility to the American people
to get the government open and to govern
them and you're right you you're
derelict in that Duty so you people
should be voted out and not have a job
you are correct keep going keep going uh
to our districts to work together and
unify and this conference is absolutely
broken and the yep you are right it is
broken it is broken and you and America
should go ahead and vote accordingly
that's what should happen oh my God you
know what maybe this one is AI maybe
yesterday the one where she's whining
about being a Nazi and people calling
her Nazi maybe that one's you know maybe
that one's not real or is real but this
one maybe a i because she's kind of
making sense here if you want to know
the honest truth if you kind of put it
together you're like yeah you probably
shouldn't be in your job that's probably
a thing that you shouldn't be is a
congress person because you guys don't
know how to [__] govern and because
you guys don't know how to govern we
shouldn't let you govern so the American
people shouldn't let you I don't know um
what's it called govern like maybe we
shouldn't let you do that so she's right
let's see what else she's got to say
reason why we're broken is because
Republicans worked with Democrats and
put us
here okay she she she [__] proved me
wrong she proved me wrong she's still an
idiot oh [__] I had all the faith in the
world in there I really did I tried I
tried to have all the faith in the world
oh we got a we got a picture here uh
from the small Furniture Factory oh wait
wait a second wait a second um we've got
we've got oh yeah boy they really are
creating jobs over there the tiny the
tiny the Tiny Furniture Factory it looks
like there are elves and both ties
actually making this tiny furniture look
at this I'm not getting you look and
there's little bitty tiny L's too so
there's big lv's there's tiny lv's
there's big chairs little chairs oh boy
they're really creating jobs over there
at the uh at the Tiny Furniture Factory
oh man Joe Baden creating jobs at the
tiny elf Factory oh wait wait wait well
we got another image here from the
factory now I don't want to I don't want
to uh you
know not not show you guys what's going
on here at the Tiny Furniture Factory
here's another image in inside that same
Factory so it looks like elves and bow
ties are all over that factory and
they're making tiny desk over there I
don't I don't see this must just be the
tiny Trump desk uh part of the factory I
don't see any tiny um mcbow TI speaker
MCB TI cheers in this one so oh
man by the way if you guys want to see
all this art I'm I'm serious we're gonna
post it um over in the Discord so make
sure you get in the Discord if you like
some of this art that's coming out we're
we're gonna make it available for you to
share like we're not GNA hoard this
stuff and and you guys aren't gonna have
to take screenshots of the show or
anything we're going to share this stuff
with you as we make this stuff on the
Fly and on the go with the show here we
want it to be more interactive with the
show and the art and stuff um so we want
you guys to get in on the gag and and as
we get better and better at this the
memes and the pictures and stuff will be
better and better so you guys just go
share this around the [__] internet
so get in on the Discord they'll be over
there we'll post all this stuff
and and there's stuff that we won't even
show on the show that'll end up over
there and really
honestly there's a lot of folks that
share a lot of memes in the Discord so
like if you're looking for a meme uh
place like a meme a pile of memes
there's piles there's mountains of memes
over on the Discord so make sure you get
to the Discord and when you go into the
Discord make sure you verify at the
Welcome Center there's a Welcome Center
there you can verify and really honestly
if you want more access to the Discord
go to patreon.com thony michs or go to
the tony.com join the patreon there and
you'll get more access because I'm GNA
do a show tomorrow morning the an hour
before it's not really a show it's more
like a discussion we call it the
producers corner so we meet every Monday
morning and Friday morning before the
show an hour before the show and we just
discuss the news and we kind of talk
about the news stories find out what's
important what's on everybody's mind
sometimes we just shoot the [__] in
there we're just talking to each other
um so it's great fun uh on Monday
mornings and Friday mornings you guys
can join the producers Corner over on
Discord that's where we have it but you
sign up at patreon and you got to sign
up on patreon and Discord with the exact
same email and it'll it'll be automatic
so if you join the $20 tier listen the
$20 tier on patreon join the $20 tier or
higher you will be you'll get access to
the producers corner but if you just
join
patreon um you get access to the patreon
chat because there's a patreon chat on
Discord for just PE the members of
patreon that can talk to each other too
so get in on that go to the Tony
michaels.com check that out and make
sure you're sharing this art around uh
that that uh my friend rat rat where are
you here there's rat thanks rat thanks
for all the great art we really
appreciate it uh you being the mascot of
the show rat here give him some credit
there too so all right let's get back to
I know Gabe Sanchez is going to be
coming up what was that live uh and I
think he's going to be joining us before
the show before his show here maybe he
can give us an idea of what he's going
to be covering directly after this now
again here's the thing if you on YouTube
or you're on Twitch you'll go directly
to Gabe Sanchez's show what was that
live everyone keeps asking where Gabe is
Gabe has his own show now on Tuesdays
Wednesdays and Thursdays and he joins me
here during the week before his show to
give you kind of an idea what he's going
to talk about and then he joins me for
bonehead of the week on Fridays like we
always do in the second hour we do
bonehead of the week which you'll be
able to vote for tonight on Discord so
go go join the Discord it's super
important I know it's a new thing but
listen here's the thing if you hate
[__] Twitter you're gonna love the
Discord because it's not a [__]
dumpster fire over there like it's like
our own little social media it's like
our own little close-knit social media
because really on Twitter you're only
talking to a couple hundred people at a
time anyways now with Elon unless you
buy a blue check you're really not
talking to that many people it's hard to
talk to more people if you don't have a
blue check because they're really kind
of [__] they're really they're really
throttling you over there but on the
Discord it's our own little social media
Universe like we get to create our own
little Community we really do um so get
in on the Discord seriously it's it's
great over there you're going to love
the people over there the same people in
all the chats it's the [__] them fam and
you're going to love it okay let's see
what else news we have as we're awaiting
um Jim Jordan or um Gabe Sanchez but
listen I've got some news from the house
floor here's here's some news from the
house floor uh here's the business that
they took care of today in your
government this is why Republicans voted
for them in the majority is to do our
work the work of the American people
let's listen in and show how they're
doing the work of the American
people pursuant to Clause 12a of rule
one the chair declares the house in
recess subject to the call of the
chair oh the tiny due to the call of the
tiny chair with the little gabble and
he's not slamming the gabble so hard
anymore speaker mcbo tie here no
election no
speaker their party is broken they're a
disaster absolute [__] disaster he is
uh so there's there's the uh the view
from the house floor as they do
America's work oh man they're working
hard for Americans going to the house
floor for two and a half minutes to call
a recess so they cannot do no work for
the rest of the day the [__] out of
here
wow
whoosh this is the American
people this is who they elected to do
their to do their their
work oh boy let's see if we can get any
more responses from um any more
responses from Republicans on this issue
of the house being derel and its Duty oh
wait wait do we have um yeah okay here's
Tennessee holler has some uh news on
Trump's attorney here uh for pleading
guilty here's a video Let's see yes do
you understand that by pleading guilty
you G oh oh sorry
let's of these charges after trials yes
has anyone okay so this is actually
where she's uh doing her plea agreement
in court now you can see here this is
Sydney pal and you'll hear her voice
saying yep yep I am guilty the words
guilty let's listen do you understand
that by pleading guilty you are giving
up the right to have the charges against
you proven Beyond A Reasonable Doubt yes
do you understand that by pleading
guilty you are giving up the right to
appeal if convicted of these charges
after trials yes has anyone forced
threatened or promised you anything in
order to enter into this guilty plea
other than what is recited in the
documents now how do you plead to five
counts of conspiracy to commit inter
intentional interference with
performance of election duties and one
count of conspiracy to commit
criminal to commit Criminal
Trespass oh boy did you he that five
counts to overturn elections and one
count to trespass in the Coffee County
election office let's hear how she
plead my Approach for a
second changed the trespass count has
changed six count
yep oh
oh oh oh wait wait wait it's different
crimes it's different crimes because she
didn't want those crimes on her record
um she didn't want those crimes on her
record so we we we did a deal where she
would turn on Trump and tell the truth
for other crimes okay keep going you
plead to the six counts of conspiracy to
commit intentional interference with
performance of election duties
guilty there you have it you stupid
[__] manga
bastards
guilty
[__]
guilty what else do you want do you need
do you need more do you need more do you
want more because I mean do you
understand that by pleading I mean we
can give you more if you need
more [__] around and find out or what
you can do or what you can do is just
pluck your head out of your [__] ass
here and and realize that what we've
been saying about the the orange mango
musolini Jesus the Cheeto dust q and on
Grandpa poopy pants all that [__] we've
been saying about him the entire time
since like I don't know 2015 it's it's
all been the [__]
truth you are the ones who are the Sheep
you are the ones who are delusional it
is not us it is it is you that does not
understand the truth and you won't you
you won't you you you'll keep [__]
doing this stupid [__] um let's see this
oh wait wait a second I hear I hear
something what what is that what is that
can you guys can you guys hear that who
is with the last name s
Chee who this is with the last name wa
it feels like we're going to get a
Cheeto chop it feels like we're going to
get a Cheeto
chop Cheeto chop Cheeto
chop get that [__] out of here this
immature oh my God that guy with the
last name SES
that guy that guy with the last name
sesey with the last name s cron the cron
oh the creton he loves to say that he
loves to say that what what what are you
crans doing over there on what was that
live today what do you guys tell today
we're gonna of course talk about Sydney
pow we're gonna cover Jim Jordan Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan that guy
that would be the one that would I
turned a blind eye and begged wrestlers
not to report the sex crimes being
committ Comm against them um so I'm
going to talk about that I'm going to
talk about what seems to please make
sure you're going to talk about speaker
MCB because apparently Mar Taylor green
is not on the on the mcbo tiai train she
does not want MCB so there's already
Mutiny about there's already there's
Mutiny there's Mutiny for Trump to be uh
speaker I don't know if you heard about
that there's also also McCarthy is is
telling Matt gates to sit down oh really
um so there's tons of uh tons
of it's insane it's crazy it's almost
like they were the ones who created this
mess you know it would and then they're
like no it's the it's the
Democrats the Democrats they did
it they spilled the ketchup I was
telling the audience I think they're
creating jobs uh the Republicans are
creating jobs in ketchup factories
they're creating jobs in rake factories
and they're creating jobs in Tiny
Furniture factories I don't know if you
seen speaker MCB TI but he changed the
chair to a small chair I did I saw that
you know I just want to point to
something out because I have a I've got
a what was that on Jim Jordan and Nancy
ma because I'm like look regardless of
him not getting elected put his
speakership bit on pause whatever we
should never never forget what he did or
rather lack thereof but I just want to
say Nancy and I'll talk about this on
the show Nancy Pelosi is 5'5 Patrick M
McHenry is between 53 and 5'6 they're
roughly the same size what kind of what
kind of margin is that 53 and 56 that's
three in I haven't I haven't what high
heel boots he's wearing like the or
something I'm just saying this is what I
found online but what I will say before
I leave to go do my show is that they're
roughly the same they're roughly the
same size and Nancy Pelosi not never
never once did she had to replace the
chair so she looked
larger oh white male fragility at its
best that's for sure get the hell out of
here go do your show everyone stick
around for Gabe Sanchez what was that
live here on YouTube and twitch you're
going to want to stick around if you're
here you'll go directly there and make
sure make sure you help us get to 20,000
subscribers we're so close to 19,000 if
we're not there already hit the
Subscribe button for the Tony Michaels
podcast go join the Discord follow us on
Twitch and also watch us on Facebook
live go to the Tony michaels.com find
all those links there I appreciate all
of you that pitched in yesterday for hat
money I I bought a couple hats that are
going to piss the [__] Maga off in
the shorts so I'll show you those
tomorrow we'll get to it sometime I
promise maybe I'll post some pictures on
social media get the hell out of here go
to what was that live same time same
place
tomorrow Surfs Up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast podast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking